today on the matt while show a proposed
law in texas has propelled the left to
openly defend child drag shows one such
defender says that child childhood
innocence is a myth and it's fueled by
prejudice a revealing admission we'll
talk about it also a crazed leftist
tries to kill brett kavanaugh but you
never know about that if you rely on the
corporate media for your news plus joe
biden disintegrates on live tv while
talking to jimmy kimmel joy behar claims
that black people don't have guns we
will fact check that claim and a
disneyland employee is feeling the heat
for intervening in a marriage proposal
in our daily cancellation a popular
youtuber debunks my film what is a woman
or so i'm told we'll take a look and see
how he did all of that and much more
today on the matt walsh
[Music]
have you ever heard of data brokers
they're the middlemen collecting and
selling all those digital footprints you
leave online they can stitch together
detailed profiles which include your
browsing history online searches
location data then they sell the profile
to a company who delivers you a targeted
ad
well no biggie you might think well you
might be surprised to learn that these
same data brokers also are also selling
your information to the department of
homeland security
to the irs i for one don't want the
taxman showing up at my door because of
some search i did on my phone so to mask
my digital footprints i protect myself
with expressvpn
one of the easiest ways for brokers to
aggregate data and tie it back to you is
through your device's unique ip address
which also reveals information about
your location when you're connected to
expressvpn your ip address is hidden
that makes it much more difficult for
data brokers to identify who you are
expressvbn also encrypts 100 of your
network data to keep your data safe from
hackers on public wi-fi that's why i
have the expressvpn app downloaded on
all of my devices phone computer even my
home wi-fi router all i do is tap one
button to turn it on
and unprotected it's really that easy so
make sure your online activity and data
is protected with the best vpn money
money can buy visit expressvpn.com
walsh right now get three months for
free through my special link that's
expressvpn exp ress
welsh expressvpn.com
walsh to learn more
well you can't say they didn't warn us
you may remember just a year ago when
the gay men's choir in san francisco
went viral with a song promising that
they'll convert our children and turn
them gay and uh they weren't lying you
know that's of course that was far from
the beginning of the left's efforts to
recruit children into the alphabet cult
but they did ramp up their campaign
considerably over the past year we've
seen them in the mainstream come out
explicitly in favor of teaching
kindergartners about gender fluidity and
transgenderism again something that was
happening before this year but now the
only difference is that they're very
open in defending it and now in response
to a proposed bill in texas to outlaw
child drag shows we're seeing them
circle the rainbow wagons around that
particular brand of debauchery uh some
of the defenses of the practice have
have come in the form of sort of feigned
obtuseness well i don't see what the big
deal is drag isn't sexual is it
someone needs to explain to me why this
is so harmful to kids now as i've been
arguing now for days the correct
response to that kind of thing is to
place the burden back on them i don't
need to and shouldn't have to explain to
you why drag shows are harmful to kids
given that your site is introducing this
concept you must explain why it is
helpful to kids
in what way is a child's life enhanced
by putting a dollar bill in the thong of
a cross-dressing man while he gyrates
around a gay bar tell me why this should
exist see it's your idea you have to
defend it but others on the left have
been more open and unabashed in their
child drag show advocacy entertainment
weekly this morning has this headline it
says drag artists slam texas bill that
could ban minors from drag shows
the article quotes a number of drag
artists quote unquote
the term being used very loosely as
we'll see who insists that we would be
oppressing them if they're prevented
from cross-dressing in front of children
they feel a deep and powerful urge to
put on women's clothing and dance for
young children and any interference
would be very painful for them to
explain not exactly in those words but
just about
one drag queen
who has spoken out is um named maxi
glamour
and describes himself as a non-binary
drag quote demon queen and you can see
from the pictures on his website that he
takes the demon role
quite seriously
he posted a tweet saying
kids are future rock stars they're
future painters future museum curators
or even future critics it's important
that they grow up in a world where art
is all around them because in the future
they'll be the ones keeping it alive
now accompanying the caption is footage
of him in full drag demon attire
performing the flute for a group of
toddlers the whole scene is like
something out of a creepy medieval fable
let's uh let's watch for just a second
so there you go i and i still i just
don't understand why these dudes always
look like
you know
zombie
marge simpsons or something
now again
you must explain if you're an advocate
for this why do kids need that
how does that help them how are they
enriched by a cross-dressing man in a
demon costume playing the flute for them
they call this art but even just judged
on pure aesthetic grounds it's ugly
gaudy
vulgar
that goes for all drag i mean we can't
even be tempted to buy the it's good to
expose your kid to art excuse because
along with being overtly sexual and
inappropriate it's terrible art loud
obnoxious hideous there's no beauty or
talent or skill involved
if i wanted my kids to be exposed to
talentless distasteful garish loud lurid
garbage i can simply turn on the tv and
flip to almost any channel so i don't
need drag shows for that
but art of course has nothing to do with
it a woman named natalie nguyen who's a
youtuber a political commentator she
gets to the real heart of the matter she
tweeted yesterday quote random drag
queens in public spaces pose exactly
zero threat to children these people
don't care about protecting children
they care about protecting quote
childhood innocence ignorance
romanticized a [ __ ] fantasy made up
by adults reflecting every adult
prejudice
oh well there it is right
childhood innocence she says is a
fantasy it is romanticized something
that adults made up because we're
prejudiced she's opposed to childhood
innocence even in theory
she doesn't think that children are
innocent or that they should be
this is why she draws a false
distinction between protecting children
and protecting childhood innocence
well they don't want to protect children
they just want to protect childhood
innocence
which is like saying to someone uh well
you don't care about health you you're
you only care about nutrition
yes well nutrition is an important
aspect of health you can't have good
health without good nutrition just as
you can't protect children without
protecting their innocence
now a child's innocence isn't the only
thing we ought to protect we should
protect their physical safety too of
course but you can't carve out their
innocence
throw it on the trash heap and then
claim that you care about protecting
children otherwise
this hostility to childhood incidents
innocence is most tragically of all
shared by an increasing number of
parents themselves that's the elephant
in the room the elephant that's watching
the drag queen in the room in every one
of these videos all of those children
have parents
parents who brought them to the event
parents who have dedicated themselves to
the destruction of their own child's
mind and soul
parents of this kind will will sink to
unimaginable debts
in an effort to corrupt and destroy
their own children in fact one rising
trend on tick tock right now are videos
of parents crowd funding
their children's castration and
mutilation so here's just one this is a
uh i'm actually not exactly sure what
this is to be honest but it's a parent
of some kind
who is soliciting funds
from the internet
for this purpose in order to do this to
a child
so
watch
those of you don't know my name is lyric
um
today making a video that isn't like the
other content that i typically make
um basically
i'm raising money to help fun my son's
transition related costs
i'm sharing this with his permission
um basically
we already have a diagnosis of gender
dysphoria for him
um we have gotten his blood work done
and we need to start him on puberty
blockers as soon as possible
now i personally i didn't i transitioned
later so i wasn't familiar with how
puberty blockers worked
um basically
my insurance doesn't cover this
which is wonderful right um
the generic version of lupron
that we have a 22.5 milligram dose that
is going to cost out of pocket 468
per shot
and
each shot lasts three months
so
we need four of these
a year
um
it's what close to two thousand dollars
um i have already exhausted
most of my funds i need help
i want to raise money to help cover his
transition related costs as um
it's very difficult to come out with
that sort of money
on short notice um i know that i'm
asking a lot
but i would do anything to make sure
that
he is able to continue his transition
oh you're running out of funds are you
well good i hope you go bankrupt
i i wish bankruptcy upon you
uh i wish poverty and bankruptcy upon
you that's what i hope
if that's if that's the only thing
that's gonna protect your kid
from what you want to do
to your child
we talk about parental rights
but
i think we should probably be more
specific
because this is also a a claim now this
is a response
by the left when we talk about you know
parents bringing their kids to drag
shows and parents transitioning their
kids and the the left now will you'll
often hear them say well i thought you
cared about parental rights
well i do
but what do
what do you have the right to do as a
parent i mean what are your parental
rights exactly we would all agree that
parents don't have the right to do
anything they want with to or around
their children i think we would all
agree at least in theory with that so
what do we mean by parental rights what
we mean or should mean is that parents
have the right to care for their
children protect their children and love
and nurture them
that's what you have the right to do and
as always with rights it would probably
be more helpful and more clarifying to
use a different r word responsibility
okay you have a responsibility
to do all of these things for your child
and with any with any human right on the
on the flip side of the coin there's
always responsibility that we should be
talking about and when it comes to
parental rights it's not even on the
flip side of the coin it's the same
thing whenever you're talking about your
parental rights that is also your
responsibility to your child
god has given you
this mission you've been entrusted with
that task
but if you won't do it
if you will in fact do the opposite
working to corrupt pervert and destroy
the very child that you're called to
protect then you should lose all of your
rights i mean i talk about i'm saying
all of your rights your parental rights
you should lose and every other right
and be locked in a prison cell until you
die
there are many parents who deserve that
treatment this this is the groomer's
secret weapon
he has many parents
as allies
problem begins as always at homes
and that's the part of the story i think
that we need to start
really talking about
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if you've been listening to my
show for a while you know that i've been
an activist against the lazy grocery
shoppers who don't put their grocery
carts away well i have some unfortunate
news
you've probably heard in some of these
other reads the grocery carts attacked
me in my own car
again i think we're pretending
unfortunately when i was pulling out of
my parking spot a rogue grocery cart
crashed into my car
totaling it and nearly killing me there
are two lessons we can take away from
one don't be lazy put your shopping
carts away so i don't have to suffer and
two you can solve an issue like mine
quickly and without breaking the bank by
just visiting rockauto.com they have the
touch-up paint and pens that are easy to
use just as easy as a magic marker
rockauto.com is an online family-owned
business that sells all the auto parts
you could ever possibly need that are
specific to your own vehicle their
prices are shockingly reasonable and
their shipping is quick so no matter
what's going on with your car you can
trust rockauto to get you what you need
fast rock auto has a very user friendly
website and they make it easy for you to
pick the right parts for your specific
car you'll see photo specs and even
installation tips so you can feel
confident that you're choosing the
correct parts for your vehicle so what
are you waiting for go to rockauto.com
for your auto part needs today and write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so they know that i'm the one that
sent you that's rockauto.com to shop for
your auto parts today
okay so here's the uh the story
it is this story it's
should be the biggest news story of the
day the week um the month and but if you
go to and i i just i
real quick just pulled up some of these
uh mainstream media sites just to take a
look at it
cbs news on right up at the the top of
the home page no mention of it
uh nbc news
top of the home page no mention of it
cnn no mention of it on the top of the
homepage
uh and and you go down from there of
course we're talking about the attempted
assassination of brett kavanaugh okay so
this is someone who attempted to
assassinate a supreme court justice
yesterday
and the major corporate media outlets
today
aren't even it's like it didn't happen
and you i we can't even say they moved
on from it already because they they
just simply hardly acknowledged it at
all ever
here's the daily wires reporting it says
a man allegedly caught lurking near u.s
supreme court justice brett kavanaugh's
home early wednesday has been charged
with attempted murder of a federal judge
the department of justice confirmed to
the daily wire a criminal complaint was
filed today against uh charging nicholas
john roski age 26
for federal charges of attempted murder
of a supreme court justice
he was arrested in a washington suburb
of chevy chase maryland early wednesday
says that he traveled to kavanaugh's
home armed with weapons and burglary
tools with the intent to kill the
justice and prevent him from ruling on
second amendment and abortion cases so
yeah that's one of the ironies here is
that this uh maniac was going to kill
somebody with a gun was really concerned
about uh about gun control and he was
worried that brett kavanaugh would
you know would prevent gun control
legislation from and and also he was
worried about the abortion
about roe v wade protecting roe v wade
and he was willing to kill someone in
order to do it
um
he had a it says an inventory search of
the seized suitcase and backpack reveal
a black tactical chest rig and tactical
knife a glock 17 pistol with two
magazines and ammunition
pepper spray zip ties a hammer
screwdriver nail punch crowbar pistol
light
duct tape hiking boots with padding on
the outside of the soles and other items
so the um he was fully prepared to do
this and was going to do it
and um and he planned to kill himself
after he did it so this was this is a
murderous lunatic
fully capable of doing this had all the
had all the
the tools he needed to carry out this
crime
and was uh and was willing to give his
own life in the process
uh you would think a major major story
and although this does not need to be
pointed out
and has already and yet has already been
pointed out i will say it also
uh that if this was i mean you can only
imagine if this was um one of the
liberal justices
if this was someone coming after
sotomayor or kagan
or if uh ruth bader ginsburg was still
alive and on the court
and there was some crazed right winger
who showed up at their house or was on
the way to to to one of their their
homes
with all these weapons and this plan
can imagine if it was a pro-lifer
reverse this around
[Music]
and a pro-life are upset about an
impending ruling in favor of abortion
rights
on the way to one of their homes to
kidnap them and murder them
it would be the only thing that the
media talked about
for the next i don't know
two months
and even after they moved on to
something else it would it would
constantly constantly be revisited like
we would never ever move on from it as a
society just like with january 6 it
would be just like that
and they would compare the event to
911 pearl harbor in terms of
significance
but in this case uh they don't want to
talk about it one of the reasons they
don't want to talk about it is because
they realize that um
that this is
in large part their fault
you know the media and democrats going
out saying that uh
that you know the conservative justices
and you know we're going to overturn roe
v wade in overturning roe v wade it's a
it's a clear and present danger to women
you know they're going to they're going
to enact a handmaid's tale scenario
women are going to be enslaved
well when you say that to people who are
already predisposed to be violent and
crazy you are inviting them to do
exactly what this guy tried to do
let's go back and remember chuck schumer
um
chuck schumer was just a few months ago
up in front of a crowd
and let's remember what he said
i want to tell you gorsuch i want to
tell you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions
there
you will pay the price now what you what
you heard there is far more explicit
than anything donald trump ever said to
the protesters on january 6.
well actually it goes the other way
because
donald trump was was explicit in saying
that this was going to be a peaceful
demonstration
um
but that
you're going to pay the price now there
isn't even an innocent interpretation
available for something like that
now you could claim that chuck schumer i
didn't really he didn't really mean that
he wanted anyone to go
kill
justice kavanaugh
but he also didn't uh he he didn't not
want someone to go kill justice
kavanaugh it wasn't he certainly wasn't
going out of his way to make sure that
didn't happen
but whatever his intentions were you're
gonna pay the price if you arrive at
this decision he's a justice
at a at best you're trying to put social
and political pressure on a supreme
court justice
intimidate them that way in order to
change a potential ruling
so one way or another that's it that's
an open threat
um
there should be republicans right now in
congress
you know calling for
chuck schumer to be brought up on
charges of incitement
look what they're doing to marjory
taylor green trying to prevent her from
ever running for reelection
she's never done anything close to that
and if she had done that if marjorie
taylor green had given a speech
targeting liberal justices and saying yo
pay the price for this
and then a few months later some crazed
right winger showed up at one of their
homes with guns and duct tape
she'd be in jail she would go to jail
for that marjorie taylor green
um being prevented from ever running for
office again that would be the least of
her problems
republicans need to need to actually
start playing offense on this kind of
thing
there's no reason not to
you have the public on your side this is
totally inexcusable
and even after all this happened
even after someone tried to show up to
kill justice kavanaugh protesters
still showed up at kavanaugh's house
yesterday i think we have the footage of
that this is after all this happened
and uh they still showed up let's play
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you see the cops there they've got
justice kavanaugh's house
surrounded okay so they're protecting
the house but they're also just standing
there why don't you arrest these punks
what they're doing is illegal this is an
attempt to intimidate a supreme court
justice after someone just tried to kill
him this is an intimidation tactic
and it's not legal
and not to mention even if there's no
supreme court justice you there's other
disturbing the piece
when you're walking around a residential
neighborhood
with bull horns and banging on drums
if i went outside in my own neighborhood
with a bullhorn i was banging on drums
it wouldn't be long before the cops
showed up and said you can't do that
here this is disturbing the piece at a
minimum
but they're allowed to basically do what
they want
and as far as i know no republicans are
are calling for charges against any of
the democrats who openly called for
exactly this
including whoever leaked that opinion
that as far as i'm concerned the leaker
of the spray of the supreme court
opinion should now be brought up uh
along with whatever other charges you
can you can put on them should now be
brought up on attempted murder charges
also because that this was
the the
reason for leaking the opinion
it was throwing this out there so that
to prevent by whatever means
this opinion from going forward
in spite of all this you know msnbc uh i
said that they kind of ignored this but
they did have uh
maybe that's that's not entirely fair
because they did yesterday they were
talking about the problem of violent
extremists
domestic terrorism this is on the same
day when uh when a left-wing terrorist
tried to kill a supreme court justice
and so they're talking about the issue
and they are acknowledging it let's
listen
replacement theory has become political
ideology
frank if mr whitfield's mother was
killed by foreign terrorists the
democrats and the republicans on the
committee would be promising him the
moon um
what is i mean is it as obvious as it
seems that domestic violent extremists
are an important part of the voting
coalition on the right i mean what is
the structural impediment to pardoning
the homeland against domestic violent
extremism
oh right uh okay well they're talking
about the
violent extremists on the right
it it and she says in fact they're a
voting bloc that's how numerous they are
which uh which again if they're that
numerous
i mean there's a voting bloc thousands
millions
and yet it's just with it's just very
odd that with one exception
every time we have seen mobs of violent
people
um acting out
with with political motivations
every single time with one exception
they've been on the left isn't that
interesting
well while this is going on uh joe biden
decided to go down to uh california and
visit with jimmy kimmel
because that's the priority here again
supreme court justice was uh attempted
murder but he's on jimmy kimmel
and we'll play a couple clips here here
he is talking about the communication
problems
that the white house is admitting
i think that the white house has some
communication problems and even he
himself has communication problems and
then this is very helpful he actually
demonstrated his own communication
problems while talking about them so
watch
so there's a lot of major things we've
done
but what we haven't done is we haven't
been able to communicate it in a way
that is uh um
i might say another way well see that's
kind of perfect yeah well i've been able
to communicate but look how the press
has changed
look how the press is it has changed oh
listen i i get it i know you get you
overstand it you don't just understand
you overstand it
but here's the deal
one of the things is that it's very
difficult now
to have a
um
even
with notable exceptions even though
really good reporters they have to get
number clicks on on on nightly news
so instead of asking a question anyway
it's just everything gets
gets sensationalized and weighs it but
i'm convinced we can get through this we
have to get through it and one of the
things look i'm going to take a break
and then we'll talk a little bit more
don't mind i'm sorry i'm sorry
[Applause]
he didn't finish one of those sentences
did you notice that he he started so
that was a collection of sentences
that were
started and then abandoned before he
finished them that's it that's his style
of speaking now that he starts a
sentence and then it trails off and he
picks up a new thought trails off picks
up a new thought
and jimmy kimmel's sitting there trying
his best
to help him out i mean that really the
whole conversation really reminds me
it is it's very much kind of the tone
and tenor
of uh of a
you know
a a grandson sitting in a nursing home
talking to his senile
gran grandfather
that's that's exactly what's happening
here
and that's not even the worst clip i
think the worst one is this listen to
this
you turn on the tv look at the ads
when's the last time you saw biracial
couples on tv when's the last time you
saw the way i mean people are selling
products they do ads to sell products
and they sell products when people they
appeal to people this generation is
going to change everything we just got
to make sure we don't give up there's an
ability for us to do everything from and
increase the the access to education
healthcare look what we did in
healthcare
yeah you know it's really bad when um i
mean i i can't even stand this guy but
i'm so embarrassed for him that i can't
i it's hard for me to watch it anymore
the second-hand embarrassment is so
overwhelming that i can't even watch it
um and
and it's like we should be
i don't like him so the fact that he's
embarrassing himself and i also think
that he's a that he's just he's a bad
guy on top of everything else and as
i've said before the fact that he's
going senile in front of the entire
world that is also his fault
because he is was so obsessed with with
with power
that uh he just kept
grasping for it even as he knew that he
was losing his mental and physical
faculties um and and now he's
embarrassing himself
in front of the world
totally on him but it's still really
hard to watch because it's so
embarrassing
never mind the fact that uh he he's he's
got no
sense of of even what decade we're
living in so he says when's the last
time you saw a biracial couple in an
advertisement um i don't know when's the
last time i saw a biracial couple in it
in a tv ad well the last time i saw a tv
ad was the last time i saw that because
like 95 a better question is when's the
last time you saw a straight white
couple in a tv commercial it's pretty
rare these days
that's what jumps out of you if you ever
see every once in a while you see you're
like wow i didn't know this was still
happening
so i don't know 95
of uh tv couples are are
at least biracial
he's just uh he and then he's been in
the last clip before that he talks about
the nightly news and he says that the
anchors on the nike they need clicks on
the nightly news
he's just he's he's almost there the
click thing but he's kind of combining
that with the nightly news
it's uh it is
embarrassing and it's it's
long since gotten to the point where
it's really not funny anymore because um
it never actually was all that funny
even if you feel like all you could do
is laugh at times uh this person is in
charge of the country supposedly anyway
and everyone know that knows that he's
lost his mind everyone including
all of our enemies
across the world
all right
here's someone else who's um
long since lost her mind joy behar had
some thoughts about
gun laws on the view and i thought this
was pretty great and it was an applause
line the audience loved it but listen to
this
most ar-15 owners are former military
thirty-five
here's the thing once black people get
guns in this country the gun laws will
change trust me
all the train seals clapping for that
once black people get guns in this
country i'll tell you what
you know you can do that with anything
hey
once black people have cars in this
country
those republicans are going to want to
outlaw cars
once black people
once black people are eating pancakes in
this country you watch
right wingers they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna shut down all the
ihops once the black people have the
pancakes
once black people are wearing shoes in
this country
they're gonna shut down foot locker the
right wingers
what the world is she talking about i
kind of want to see the rest of that
clip because there are two black women
on the on the stage there and did they
well i don't need to see it to know i'm
sure they didn't correct her on that
point
um and it's supposed to be that's
supposed to be something in defense of
black people but of course once again
it's just
insulting and patronizing and demeaning
yeah um
punch line here in case you didn't know
is that uh black people do have guns in
this country and uh any black person in
this country who does not have a gun
that's not because there's any law
preventing them from doing so
at least there's not any law preventing
them based on race from doing so
um all right i want to play this for you
so redskins defensive coordinator jack
del rio and i am still calling them the
redskins uh i'm gonna i decided i'm
gonna dead name this team
so uh redskins defensive coordinator
jack del rio tweeted this week pointing
out
the inconsistency between how the blm
riots were covered
and how they were handled versus the
january 6th riots
and
so you know that of course that's going
to provoke a lot of backlash and outrage
everything that you expect came from
that and he addressed the controversy
during a press conference and i was kind
of when i i knew that the setup for this
and then i saw the clip then and i saw
the headline that he was addressing the
controversy i was expecting
what we always get which is the back
pedal the apology
and um
very pleased to find out that's not
exactly what happened
listen
you want to talk about it i'd talk about
with anybody yeah no problem at any time
but uh
but they're not
i'm just expressing myself
and uh i think we all as americans
have the right to express ourselves
especially if you're being respectful
i'm being respectful
i just asked a simple question really
did i
let's get right down to it what did i
ask
a simple question
why are we not
looking into those things if we're going
to talk about it
why are we not looking into those things
because it's kind of hard for me to say
i can
realistically look at it i see the
images on tv
people's livelihoods are being destroyed
businesses are being burned down
no problem and then we have a dust up at
the capitol
well there's nothing burned down
and we're not going to talk about we're
going to make that a major deal i just
think
it's kind of two standards
and if we apply the same standard
and we're going to be reasonable with
each other let's have a discussion
that's all it was let's have a
discussion we're americans let's talk it
through
i'm for i'm for us
you know
having a great opportunity to have a
fulfilled life
uh
like i said every way every which way i
can
when i'm here it's about love and
respect
damn it
i i wanted for once to give somebody
some credit because that
he said something and the me sports
media is offended by it media's offended
by how dare you say that compare blm to
january 6th which which i agree by the
way that you can't really compare the
blm riots to january 6 only because the
blm riots were a thousand times worse in
by every measure uh uh
death toll
damage
done you know uh and it's easy for the
death toll to be worse because there was
no
death toll from january 6 except for
the uh except for ashley babbitt who was
killed by a by a capital police officer
um
so but he says this and then you heard
him there
that's when you expect to get the
apology and said he kind of doubles down
great
and i want to finally give someone
credit for not apologizing and then
while that clip is playing i hadn't done
this before i probably should have and i
looked it up and uh he did apologize
after that so
damn it
i thought we finally had someone so he
tweeted shortly after that uh clip went
viral he tweeted this i made comments
earlier today in referencing the attack
that took place on the united states
capital on january 6 referencing that
situation as a dust up was irresponsible
and negligent and i am sorry i stand by
my comments condemning violence and
communities across the country i say
that while also expressing my support as
an american citizen for peaceful protest
in our country i've fully supported all
peaceful protests in america i love
respect and support all my fellow
coaches players and staff that i work
with and respect their views and
opinions
i don't know why i'm even disappointed
but
you just you just hope like one of these
times just one person
i'm just waiting for one person
to have the cancel mob coming after them
and to say i i'm not gonna apologize
even if
even if i was wrong with what i said i'm
still not and he wasn't wrong
but even if you were you still don't
apologize because these people don't
deserve it
they don't deserve your apology
they weren't hurt by anything you said
how many times i don't know how many
times i have to explain this
apologies are given
by someone
who has hurt another person
and they are given to the person who was
hurt
okay
if you've done something and nobody was
hurt
then
good news
you don't know anybody apology you're
off the hook you didn't do anything
wrong
um
if you did somehow hurt another person
then you find that person and you you
privately apologize to them
but this public apology ritual
does nothing but just encourage
and and fuel
this
mob this pitchfork mob
of phonies and losers who are just
looking for a reason to pretend to be
offended by things
and you notice that especially in sports
and in football
it's like the worst thing the greatest
offense that somebody
in the nfl can can commit
is to say something is to say is to
reveal
that
they have a similar view as the majority
of the fans
like the majority of the of nfl fans
would probably agree with jack del rio
about that
but the media says if you're in the nfl
that that you cannot do that you can't
agree with most of your fans you can't
say the worst thing you could do is to
say something that your fans agree with
that's the worst offense
damn it jack
well
maybe the next one i'll keep i'll keep
hoping okay one other quick uh thing
here this is from yahoos is a proposal
that took place at disneyland paris has
blown up on reddit and not in a good way
reddit user was gitlan
initially posted the proposal video in
the i'm a total piece of s forum and
claimed to be friends with the man who
was proposing
and he captured the clip pos destroyed
my best friend's moment he asked for
permission beforehand so okay so in this
video apparently they're at disneyland
paris
uh it's this couple and the man wants to
propose to the woman
and they're standing in this spot where
apparently people propose all the time
with the little fake castle in the
background well it's a big fake castle
but there's a fake castle uh they're
they're standing in the the same spot
and and this is and the article goes on
to explain that um
that i guess
this is one of the top 10 proposal sites
in the world people go here all the time
to get the instagram proposals
but you're not supposed to stand there
apparently so in the middle of the
proposal
the disneyland employee rushes in and
takes the ring and moves them to another
spot
let's play the video
[Applause]
[Music]
yes that's great but over here she's
going to be even better
[Music]
um i i got to say i kind of i'm not a
defender of disney uh by any means
whatsoever but
i'm kind of on the disney employee side
on this one i i sort of am
and i'll tell you why the only reason is
because like it's a proposal
so it's hopefully a once in a lifetime
thing for a lot of people it ends up not
being once a lifetime but but hopefully
it should be
and and so so why are you going
why would you want to go to the place
where a billion other people have done
the proposal it's a top 10 proposal site
so why why do you want to propose in the
most cliche way imaginable
so that you can have the same instagram
shot
that that 50 million people also have
so for that reason alone i'm i think
it's they did them a favor
redo the proposal somewhere else if you
feel like you need to make a thing out
of it like do something unique and
interesting
disneyland of all places a corporate
theme park
is where you want to start this journey
with the with the love of your life
that's the real outrage here in my
opinion
let's get now to the comment section
val says matt was unnecessarily
unnecessarily rude to the wnba players
who by the way had nothing to do with
these shenanigans i'm usually a fan of
you matt but this was low unconvincing
and part of the reason people are
deterred from the right because we keep
making unnecessarily hateful comments
about historically marginalized people
i'm not trying to cancel you for this or
anything i just hope you see where i'm
coming from
uh well i don't val and i think that's
very unfair to me um i would i
honestly i'm
i'm shocked that you would accuse me of
being rude to wnba players i would never
i i believe in the golden rule okay i
would never i'm not going to dunk on
wnba players because i wouldn't i know
they would never dunk on me
because they can't
because they can't touch the rim so
i didn't mean to use the video of the
protest at the game as an excuse to
insult the wnba
honestly i'm just impressed that they
actually record the games at all
i figured they would just have like a
stenographer or maybe a courtroom sketch
artist
drawing a picture every time somebody
makes a layup so you only got to draw
like two or three pictures in the game i
didn't mean any disrespect but i really
didn't
just to clarify
um let's see
sarah says i watched what is a woman
three times within the span of two days
and i'm gonna watch it again tonight the
obsession over watching [ __ ] spew their
nonsense
is real and matt's poker face is pure
gold that never gets old well that's
that's exactly that's how this should be
done you don't need to watch it once
watch it multiple times tell your
friends about it go to whatiswoman.com
um
lr23 says matt how do you respond to the
argument that if children don't belong
at drag shows they also don't belong at
places like hooters
however yeah i've seen this uh this if
you can even call it an argument it's
it's not an argument it's a deflection
which is not the same thing as an
argument but um how do i respond to that
well first of all who
i guess my first response is okay
i
yeah i'm not bringing my kids to hooters
so okay yeah don't i agree
i think we could probably just establish
that
you know you probably shouldn't be
bringing young kids to hooters fine
cool
um now that we've agreed on that let's
get back to talking about the drag shows
because the reason we got to talk about
that is that we don't agree on it
also um as far as i know there's not any
big societal push
to get kids into hooters
uh i know that sometimes kids are
brought into hooters but there's not
it's not a thing okay it's not there's a
there's there's not a
great effort
to do that
and um and then my third response is
that actually it's not even the same
kind of thing
um
i think it's weird to bring young kids
into hooters i decided
it's the same kind of response like why
even do that there's
a lot if you want to go to a chain
restaurant with bad food there are many
of them available to you uh why bring
the kids there so agreed you know on
that i'm not bringing my kids to hooters
but it's not the same okay that's
there's not a moral equivalence there
the drag show for kids is definitely
worse
hooters not appropriate for kids drag
show a lot a lot more inappropriate
a lot more uh
grotesque disordered
um
much more overtly sexual all those
things so it is it is a lot worse
that's the other so there's my there are
my three responses that you get for that
um
let's see
roger says matt really given the wnba
the business
of course they could use it
sir that's not that's not funny i've
just said we're not making jokes about
the wnba on this show we don't do that
here
roger you're banned from the show that's
uh that is outrageous sir
um teresa says matt you're getting close
to a million subscribers better start
practicing the dance i don't know what
you're talking about to practice and
dance what do you mean
um nate says the funniest way matt could
die is to get hit by a meteorite while
he's doing a plug for epic will i i
actually and i think i've said this
before i think it'd be a great honor to
die by meteor right that's my number one
preferred
um death if i if i get to choose you
know if i if i was able to choose from a
menu of options what's ultimately going
to take me out i think a meteor would be
pretty good especially as a big fan of
space as i am it'd be a great honor to
have something i mean think about that
you got a meteorite that's been
traveling
billions of miles like to this
destination to for this rendezvous with
with you and your head
i think i i i'd actually be okay with
that
and uh let's see i think there was one
other here
shelley says matt i read the interview
in the uk magazine i thought the
interview interviewer made a good point
these feminists are complaining about
not being included in your film
but have they included you in anything
uh no they haven't that that was a good
point i mentioned i did an interview
in a magazine in the uk and uh
some of the interview was about this
this debate in the uk among uh british
feminists about the film and about me
and
they feel that they've been somehow
marginalized because they weren't
included in the film
and um
and that is that is one of many
responses to that is uh yeah
there were no feminists and haven't been
any at any point
that are knocking on my door trying to
include me in any projects
and also just the
the gumption
the narcissism to get offended that
you're not in a movie
that someone in a different country who
you don't know and don't even like made
that's that's a that is a sense of
entitlement that is beyond anything i
can even comprehend
it would never occur to me it would
never occur to me to watch a movie or a
documentary that somebody else made and
i'm sitting there watching and thinking
why am i not in this
what
who why should you be in it i mean why
should jews specifically
and also in our film what is a woman
if you're someone who's uh you know been
in this fight for
against gender ideology madness and so
you think you should have been in the
movie
um
who in the movie should should have been
taken out to make room for use a 90
minute film
so
and we use every minute of that 90
minutes and it goes it actually goes a
little bit over 90 minutes
so who should be taken out to make room
for you because i think that every
interview we did
helped to tell the story and each
interview was powerful in its own way
um oftentimes powerful in ways that the
interviewee didn't intend
so who are we taking out that's the
other question
you let me know that
feminist and then you know maybe i'll go
back and we could just reshoot the
entire movie for you you tell me what
movie i should have made and i'll just
make it at your behest
sure
what is a woman is a huge success so we
really thank you for that this week the
film became the number one most popular
movie at home on rotten tomatoes which
is just
really mind-boggling with over 2 500
ratings and an audience score of 97
this is a must-see film that everybody's
talking about from national review
to a lot of conservative influencers
like zooby they they're talking about
how important the film is and why people
have to watch it we're changing the
gender ideology conversation and
fighting back in the culture many of the
people who hate the film despite likely
not having actually seen it still are
not able to offer any definition of what
a woman is or if you any of the
absurdity that the film points out they
simply have no meaningful response
because we're winning but without your
support none of this will be possible so
from all of us at the daily wire thank
you for that go to whatiswoman.com to
become a member and watch the film today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we will
respond to a video from
a youtuber named professor dave of the
channel professor dave explains where
presumably professor dave explains
things the channel has an impressive 2
million subscribers and this video was
sent to me by several people promising
that it contains a formidable argument
against my position on gender ideology
one person in fact says that professor
dave debunks my movie what is a woman
and i'm quite interested to see that so
let's uh go through this together
everybody seems to be furious about
trans people half of us are furious that
they exist and the other half are
furious about what the other half is
saying i would like to jump in and see
if i can clear up some of the ways that
people are talking past each other
now it's no secret that i'm a bit on the
liberal side but rest assured the left
is not going to get away scot-free on
this one they're missing the mark on a
few key points but as tends to be the
case it's bigots on the right who are
the main problem so let's start there
we're off to a rough start putting aside
dave's smug know-it-all tone and
demeanor something that seems to be a
matter of instinct for people like him
so i'm not going to hold her against him
the real problem is that in the very
first sentence he's already wildly and
intentionally mischaracterizing his
opponents in 30 seconds he gives us a
straw man and an ad ad hominem he's
doing that in the first 30 seconds he's
beginning this way
which signals that he doesn't have much
to offer beyond this point because if he
actually planned on making a compelling
argument he wouldn't come out of the
gate breezily dismissing millions of
people as bigots sorry not millions
billions
because anybody who has a problem with
basic concepts of gender ideology is a
bigot he says which means that almost
everybody in the world and who has ever
existed in the world is a bigot
professor dave begins the proceedings
with that declaration he also lies about
the nature of the opposing argument and
he does it in the laziest and frankly
dumbest way imaginable he says that the
people on the other side are furious
that trans people exist
now in reality as he's well aware we're
not furious that trans people exist but
rather we deny the underlying premise of
gender ideology if we're furious about
anything it's that this ideology is
being imposed on society especially on
children and it's causing great harm in
the process by saying that we're furious
that trans people exist he gets to
dismiss all of us as a bunch of angry
spittle-flecked rage clowns when he is
also quite well aware that when it comes
to the subject nearly all of the angry
spittle flecked rage clowns
are on the other side of the discussion
take for example the people threatening
to kill me and accusing me of genocide
for making a documentary a documentary
where i am only visibly angry one time
briefly when addressing a school board
that covered up the rape of a student so
perhaps you'll excuse my emotions
in that case
but the other point of this
mischaracterization is to pretend that
we're angry at trans people personally
rather than critical of the claims made
by trans activists
overall it's a mess and we're only 30
seconds in let's continue
the primary issue is people who deny
transgenderism these are the people who
spew the tired fox news talking points
liberals say there are 89 genders and
anyone can identify as a hamster that
sort of thing it's a deliberate
caricature of reality peddled by all the
angry conservative dudes popping up in
my feed lately who claim that nobody can
define a woman let's all take a moment
to acknowledge the problems that go
along with the ambiguity of language
sex and gender are different words that
refer to different things if you did not
know that now you do
so we we have another common rhetorical
tactic from the left and honestly i'm
quite disappointed to hear common
rhetorical tactics when i was promised
an utter destruction of my worldview and
i was looking forward to it professor
dave says it's a tired fox news talking
point that there are a lot of genders
but that's not fox's talking point
that's his talking point this is indeed
the official position of the gender
ideologue they may they may disagree on
how many genders but they all agree that
there are a lot more than two some say
there are infinite numbers facebook says
there are 58. if this sounds insane
that's not fox's fault
as for sex and gender being two
different things um i totally agree sex
refers to biology while gender is a
linguistic term that refers to words but
was co-opted by a pedophile sexologist
named john money and applied to people
in a vague and ambiguous way
dave never mentions that point he
doesn't seem to know where his own ideas
came from or or else he doesn't want you
to know
ignorant or deceptive you decide from
here professor dave provides a basically
correct definition of sex with a long
digression into intersexuality and then
gets around to talking about gender
let's listen to that
gender is a different phenomenon it is
still biological but it is a
neurochemical construct
this means that ultimately it is still
genetic in basis but it absolutely is
not determined merely by the sex
chromosomes it is tremendously more
complicated and researchers are still
working to understand the biological
basis of gender identity human
psychology is complex people need to
deal with that thoughts and feelings are
ultimately chemical phenomena we all
have a neurochemical profile that guides
how we think and feel and part of that
is gender identity the reason that we
are just now becoming equipped to
differentiate between the two phenomena
is that in the vast majority of humans
somewhere between 99 and 99.9 percent of
all people gender identity aligns with
biological sex
so gender identity has a neurochemical
basis because it's a feeling and
feelings can be traced back
to brain activity
uh okay sure
i'll buy that
the question is whether those feelings
reflect reality that's the question
an anorexic person feels that she's
overweight the feeling is a biological
phenomenon in the sense that it's
happening in her brain in the same sense
that a man feels like a woman but we
understand in her case that the feelings
are disordered incorrect wrong
delusional and so we work to treat her
brain her feelings to more accurately
align them with reality we don't say
that the anorexic is trans obese and we
don't call actually obese people cis
obese
we understand that there's physical
reality and then feelings and sometimes
feelings are out of step with reality
and when that's the case we usually
understand that the feelings are the
issue they are the problem to be solved
and so we try to solve them will
professor dave address that objection in
this video spoiler no he won't in fact
he won't honestly engage with literally
any objection raised by the opponents of
his ideology at all won't even try
common theme with these people but let's
keep listening anyway
the unfortunate linguistic coincidence
is that we use terms like man and woman
or male and female in describing both of
these phenomena that is where the
confusion arises when people insist that
one term must encapsulate both phenomena
at once
so when someone asks what is a woman
expecting to get a very simple answer
that children can understand they are
sorely mistaken the answer requires a
discussion of genetics and
neurochemistry
well i'm sorry you find it offensive
dave but yes i do deny the concept of
gender as it was conceived by john money
you accept that concept as gospel you're
offended that anybody disagrees with it
um
that's your problem meanwhile you say
that the definition of the word woman is
complicated but please note that
it's complicated is not a definition so
you still haven't defined it i never
insisted on a simple definition i simply
insist on a definition any kind of
definition some sort of meaning you can
give me a complicated one that's fine go
ahead try me give me a complicated
definition i i'm perfectly fine with
that
but you must have some definition
whereas you provide none at all
see this is a major problem for you dave
and let me try to explain why it's a
problem because and listen closely
you are using the word do you see why
that's an issue
you say the word woman is complicated
and apparently ambiguous
and hard to understand
yet you use it
you refer to women you talk about women
i bet you'd even say that you believe in
women's rights would you say that i bet
you would
this must mean that you have some solid
comprehensible idea of what a woman is
yet you never explain that idea that's a
very big problem for you dave you're
using a word that you cannot or will not
define which means either that you're
hopelessly confused and we should
dismiss you and your arguments for that
reason or you're evasive and
disingenuous and we should dismiss you
and your arguments for that reason
either way you and your arguments are in
really bad shape right now let's
continue
the acceptance for suppressed sexual
orientations came first because around
10 percent of people are gay whereas a
much smaller percentage of people are
trans but this is the natural
progression of societal evolution nearly
every binary has been shown to actually
be a spectrum and it doesn't matter how
uncomfortable it makes conservative
people
wait what
nearly every binary is a spectrum like
what
no i'm not uncomfortable with that i
just think it's nonsense it's just it's
just
that's i mean in a certain way i'm
uncomfortable around
people saying stupid things but that's
all we mean by that what are the
binaries that turned out to be spectrums
don't say gender because that's begging
the question i don't agree
with john money's concept of gender at
all it's not that i think gender is a
binary it's that i think it's a totally
useless and incoherent concept that
should be put back into the world of
linguistics and grammar where it belongs
as for sex if that's not a binary then
what is it there are males and females
there are those who are of the nature to
become pregnant and those who are of the
nature to impregnate there's no third
sex it's a binary so where is the
spectrum that everyone thought was a
binary can you give one example
as for the claim that 10 of people are
gay where did you come up with that
where'd you get that from well i'll tell
you where you got it from uh you got
that from alfred kinsey who made that
claim in his book sexual behavior of the
human male which is the same book that
contains a chart documenting the orgasms
of infants he arrives at his arguments
and his figures about human sexuality by
interviewing sex offenders and prison
inmates and lying and pretending that he
surveyed a cross-section of the
population but he didn't so that's where
you're getting your information
professor i just thought you might like
to know that let's watch a little bit
more
now as promised with the indictment of
conservatives complete i turn to
liberals and the missteps they are
enacting that are preventing resolution
number one please stop saying things
like gender is a social construct
no it is not it is a biological
construct society can't turn you trans
any more than it can turn you gay gender
is determined biologically
his indictment of conservatives was
complete without ever approaching the
vicinity of any one of our actual
arguments and then he turns to
criticized liberals to prove how fair
and objective he is
by slamming them for not being liberal
enough
he also says that society can't turn you
trans uh totally ignoring the fact that
in our society currently and only in our
society only in the west there has been
a manifold increase in trans
identification if that's not society
turning people trans what is it dave
now
i don't know what you'd say to that
because as always and like literally
every other gender ideologue i've ever
spoken to and i guarantee i've spoken
personally to many more people on your
side than you've spoken to on my side
but like all of them you don't attempt
to grapple with any of the logical
inconsistencies of your position but i
ask again anyway if society can't turn
you trans why are we experiencing an
unprecedented skyrocketing rise in trans
identifications if you say that there
have always been this many trans people
but they were all in the closet
you'll then have to explain why there
was never ever at any point ever a mass
epidemic of people committing suicide
because they were not affirmed in their
gender identity after all staple
doctrine on the left is that lack of
affirmation is dangerous because it
causes suicide well then why was that
never happening back when there were
millions and millions of supposed
unaffirmed trans people
indeed why is the suicide epidemic
happening now
when trans people are so
affirmed here's my answer
gender ideology is a modern western
social construct that didn't exist until
it was invented by psychoanalytical
quacks and then parroted mindlessly by
people like you further while pretending
that it affirms and nurtures people it
actually leads them into
self-destruction and despair
the evidence bears that out
the evidence is entirely on my side in
fact and not at all on your side because
on this topic you are wrong about nearly
everything and your underlying claims
are so nonsensical and incoherent that
you can't begin to explain them or
defend them and that's why you don't
even try
which is a long way of saying professor
dave that you are today canceled
that'll do it for us thanks for watching
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire
[Music]